Şimdi bilimsel yöntem, bilim, bilimin
doğası ya da bir problemi çözmek için
neler yaptığımızla ilgili konuşalım.
Tabii biz bilimle ilgili ilk derste bir
şeyler söyledik. Özellikle
aktarılabildiğinden,
bu sayede medeniyet
geliştirebildiğimizden bahsettik.
Bilimsel bilgi ile alakalı konuşacağımız
zaman öncelikle şunları bilmemiz lazım
arkadaşlar. Bir defa sorgulanma ve
eleştiriye açık olan bir süreçten
bahsediyoruz. Yani mesela ben yaptım
oldu bu böyledir ve işte insanlık yok
olana kadar bu bilgi böyle kalacaktır
tarzında bir şey yok. Biz sürekli
gelişen bir şeyden bahsediyoruz sonuçta.
Şimdi sürekli olarak sorgulama ve
eleştiri süreci içindedir bilim.
Bilimsel araştırmalar kişisel ön
yargılardan arındırılmış ve tarafsız
olmalıdır. Bilimsel araştırmalara
baktığınız zaman işte bana göre şöyle
diyemeyiz. Burada sebep sonuç ilişkileri
kurmalıyız ve bir sürü kontrollü
deneyden geçirildikten sonra bu
düşünceleri bir tez haline getirip
insanların bilgisine sunmalıyız. Tabii
ben birazdan size bilimsel çalışma
basamaklarından bahsederken problemi
saptama, gözlem yapma, hipotez kurma,
hipoteze dayalı tahmin yapma, kontrollü
deneyler yapma vesaire gibi bir sıralama
vereceğim. Ama şimdi dünyada birçok
bilim dalı var ve dolayısıyla arkadaşlar
birçoğunun aslında uyguladığı yöntemler
kendine özgü olabilir ama bu temel
şablonu içeriyor ve bir de biz biyoloji
dersi için anlatıyoruz. biyoloji dersi
için anlattığımızdan dolayı da hani
genellikle biyolojiyile alakalı bir
sıralama vermiş olacağım size. Bilimsel
bilgi toplumun kendisinden de
etkilenebilir. Nasıl ki bir toplumun
yetiştirdiği bir bilim insanı kendi
toplumundan çok da bağımsız olamaz
arkadaşlar. Yani bazen subjektif, öznel
olabiliyor ama biz olabildiğince
bilimsel bilginin doğasına baktığımız
zaman herkes tarafından kabul edilebilir
tarzda bir önermeyle insanların
karşısına geçmeliyiz. Bilim, gözlemler
ve deneyler sonucunda elde edilen
bilgileri organize etmek için teoriler
ve hipotezler geliştirir. Arkadaşlar
şimdi şuraya dikkat etmenizi istiyorum.
Hipotez, teori, kanun, bu tarz kelimeler
duyacaksınız. Bunlar birbirlerine
dönüşmezler arkadaşlar. Yani işte bazen
şöyle cümleler duyarız. İşte hipofiz
doğrulanırsa teori olur. İşte teori daha
da gelişmiş hale gelirse kanun olur.
Böyle cümleler yanlış arkadaşlar.
Birincisi teori ve kanun birbirine
dönüşemez. İkincisi hipotezlerin
onlarcası, yüzlercesi, belki de
binlercesi bir araya geldiğinde ortaya
bir teori çıkar. Yani hipotez teoriye
dönüşmez. Teoriler hipotezlerle
desteklenir ya da teori kanuna dönüşmez.
Bunlar arkadaşlar farklı rollere sahip
olan kavramlardır. Dikkat edeceğiz.
Bilim doğrudan gözlemler ve deneyler
aracılığıyla test edilen verilere
dayanır. Yine dediğim gibi pozitif
bilimlerden, biyolojiden bahsediyoruz.
Biyoloji ile alakalı konuşuyoruz. Çünkü
sosyal bilimler de var arkadaşlar.
Bilimin doğası gözlem, deney, analiz ve
mantıklı çıkarım yoluyla bilgi elde
etmeye dayanır demişiz. Çünkü bilimsel
araştırma sürecinde belirli ilke ve
yöntemlere sadık kalınarak çalışmalar
yürütülür ve tabii ki güvenilirliği,
geçerliliği sürekli olarak test edilir.
Bilimsel deneyler ve gözlemler aynı
koşullar altında tekrarlandığında benzer
sonuçlar vermeli. Yani
tekrarlanabilirlik bilimsel bulguların
güvenilirliğini pekiştirir. Yani ben
burada kendi laboratuvarımda bir deney
yapıyorum. Sonuçlarını insanlarla
paylaşıyorum. İnsanlar da kendi
laboratuvarlarında deney yaptıkları
zaman benim bulduğum sonuçlar gibi
sonuçlar bulmalılar. Bu sayede
arkadaşlar hem benim yaptığım çalışmalar
doğrulanmış oluyor hem de o insanlar, o
bilim insanları benim yaptığım
çalışmalardan faydalanmış oluyor. Ve
dediğim gibi bilimsel yöntemin aşamaları
birçok bilim dalında farklılık
gösterebilir. Ancak temel mantığa
baktığınız zaman bu sayfanın sağ
tarafındaki sıralamayı görürsünüz.
Gözlem yapar insanlar. bir problem
belirler. Tabii problemi belirledikten
sonra gözlem yapmaya devam eder. Veriler
elde eder. Yani kayıt altına alır bazı
bilgileri. Sonra problemin çözümüne
yönelik bir hipotez ortaya atar. Yani
geçici bir çözüm yoludur aslında
hipotez. Sonrasında hipoteze dayalı
tahmin yapar. Şimdi öğretmeniniz size
bunun sıralamasını sorarsa tahmin ve
hipoteze dikkat edin. Hipoteze dayalı
tahmin. Yani tahmin hipotezden sonra
olur. Çünkü hipoteze dayalı bir şey
yapıyorsun ve kontrollü deneyler
tasarlanır. Kontrollü deney nedir hocam?
Değişkenlerden sadece bir tanesi
değiştirilerek ve bir de kontrol grubu
kullanılarak yapılan deneylerdir.
Birazdan size somut bir şeyler
söyleyeceğim. Ve biz bu test
sonuçlarını, yaptığımız deneylerin
sonuçlarını
bir şekilde inceler, tutarlılık görürsek
işte hipotez desteklendi der ve
sonuçları duyururuz. Fakat bize bilimsel
etik şunu da söyler. Eğer senin
sonuçların hipotezi desteklemiyor ise de
bunu paylaş ki insanlar neyin ne
olduğunu bilsin. Hipotez eğer
desteklenmiyor ise reddedilir ve tekrar
arkadaşlar gözden geçirilip
yenilenebilir. Demek ki hipotezler
değiştirilebilir arkadaşlar. Eldeki
sonuçlarla tutarlı değilse. Peki burada
her biriyle alakalı, her basamakla
alakalı olabildiğince detaylı bilgi
vermeye çalıştık.
Şimdi insanlar gözlem yaparlar. Bakmakla
görmek aynı şey değildir arkadaşlar. Siz
sağınıza solunuza bakarsınız. Bilim
insanı ise görür ve ortadaki o problemi
saptadığında o problemi çözmek için
gecesini gündüzüne katar ve bir çözüm
yolu bulma uğraşı içerisine girer. Ne
dedim az önce? Gözlemi siz birkaç yere
yazabilirsiniz. Hani ezbercilik yapmaya
gerek yok. problemi belirledim. Ben hala
üzerine gözlemler yapmaya devam
edebilirim. Burada belki şöyle iki
kelime eklemekte fayda var. Bunlardan
bir tanesi nitel, diğeri nicel gözlem.
Nitel gözlemde biraz daha böyle
duyguların ön planda olduğu gözlem
olarak düşünebilirsiniz. Mesela ben şunu
söylersem eğer hava bugün çok sıcak. Bu
bir nitel gözlemdir. Çünkü kime göre
neye göre sıcak? Bana göre sıcak
değildir belki dersin. Ama nicelde
sayısal ifadeyi ön plana atarsın. İşte
bugün hava 24 derecedir. Niye? Ben çünkü
bunu termometre ile ölçtüm.
Termometremde kalibre doğru. Verileri
topladığımız zaman biz veri için ne
dedik? Kayda alınmış bilgilerdir dedik.
Bakın artık kayıt altına alıyorsunuz.
Bir yerlere yazıyorsunuz, dosyalar
oluşturuyorsunuz ve bir hipotez ortaya
atıyorsunuz. Hipotez daha önceden
belirlenen probleme cevap vermeye
çalışır. Gözlemlere ve verilere dayalı
olarak üretildiği için arkadaşlar eldeki
verilere uygun olmalı tarzında hipotez
için bir özellik söyleyebilirsiniz.
O zaman hipotez neymiş? Bir olgunun,
olayın veya durumun açıklanması için öne
sürülen test edilebilir. Çünkü bundan
sonra da ne yapacağım? Kontrollü deney
yapacağım. geçici bir öneridir. Ve
tekrar söyleyelim hipotezler arkadaşlar
değiştirilebilir, desteklenebilir ya da
çürütülebilir. Hipoteze dayalı tahmin
yapma. Bunun klasik bir kalıbı var. İşte
eğer nokta nokta ise nokta nokta dır
şeklinde. Bunun böyle tatlı tatlı
soruları olacak. Merak etmeyin. Ve biz
tahminlerin doğruluğunu artık kontrollü
deneyle test etmemiz lazım. Şimdi ne
dedim? kontrolü deney için
değişkenlerden
bir tanesi değiştirilecek. Geriye kalan
her şey sabit kalacak. Yani ben bir
bitkinin gelişimi üzerine ışığın
renginin etkisini araştırıyorsam
elimdeki bitkilerin özdeş olması
gerekir.
Ekildiği toprağın aynı olması gerekir.
Aynı miktarda sulanması, ortamın aynı
sıcaklığa sahip olması gerekir. Bakın
her şey aynı olmalı ki ben bu bitkiye
yeşil ışık, bu bitkiye kırmızı ışık
verdiğimde bitkinin gelişimini heş ışık
verirsem böyle oluyormuş, kırmızı ışık
verirsem böyle oluyormuş şeklinde
sonuçlandırabileyim.
Çünkü mantık neydi? Eğer ben gidip de
rengi araştırırken bir de saksılara
koyduğum su miktarını farklı verirsem ya
da birbiriyle alakasız iki farklı tür
bitki kullanırsam hiçbir işe yaramaz.
Hocam ben orada bir deney yapmış olmam.
Demek ki bilimsel çalışmalarda deney
yapılırken değişkenlerden bir tanesi
değiştirilir kontrollü deneylerde o da
zaten etkisi araştırılan etken
faktördür. Yani hocam işte biz buradan
bağımsız ve bağımlı değişken
kavramlarına geliriz. Eğer etkisi
araştırılan kişiden bahsediyorsam
bu bağımsız değişkendir. Çünkü ben
ışığın renginin bitkinin gelişimi
üzerine etkisini araştırıyorum. Peki
bağımlı değişken ne olur? Bağımlı
değişken de aslında buna karşı bitkinin
verdiği cevap olur. Peki bakalım.
Deney grubunda değiştirilen ve etkisi
araştırılan değişkene bağımsız değişken
denir. Mesela az önce örneğini verdiğim
ışığın rengi bağımsız değişkene bağlı
olarak ortaya çıkan ve birbirinden
farklı olabilen sonuçlar ise bağımlı
değişken olarak tanımlanır. Buraya iki
kere bağımsız yazmışım. Orayı bağımlı
değişken olarak tanımlanır. Yazın
lütfen. Tekrar edelim. Bu bitkinin
kırmızı ve yeşil ışık altında vereceği
cevap bağımlı değişken olarak tanımlanır
arkadaşlar. Şuraya dikkat edelim.
Uyarımız burada çok daha tatlı bir
şekilde yazmışız. Bağımsız değişken test
edilen tahmini ya da hipotezi
gösterirken bağımlı değişken testin
sonuçlarını yani hipotez ya da tahminin
doğru olup olmadığını gösterir. Biz
burada ne anlattıysak şimdi onun özetini
vereceğiz. Bir hipotez kurduk. hipoteze
dayalı tahmin yaptık ve test kontrollü
deneylerle
bağımsız değişkenlerin sonuçlarına
baktık. Bir çıkarımda bulunacağız şimdi
ve o çıkarımdan dolayı ya hipotezi
değiştireceğiz ya da hipotezin
doğruluğunu insanlara sunacağız.
Arkadaşlar tartışma ve sonuç. Çıkarım
bilimsel çalışma sürecinde elde edilen
verilerin yorumlanması olarak
tanımlanır. Artık bir şeyler söylemen
lazım çünkü. ve test sonuçlarından elde
edilen çıkarımlar
hipotezi arkadaşlar tamamen doğruluyorsa
doğrulanan hipotezler gerçek halini alır
ve gerçek nedir? gözlemlerle,
deneyimlerle veya doğrulanabilir
kanıtlarla desteklenen nesnel, öznel
değil, nesnel ve değişmez bilgi ya da
durumdur şeklinde ifade edilir. İşte
arkadaşlar burada siz hipotezi
doğruladınız ama test sonuçları hipotezi
doğrulamazsa hipotezi bir gözden
geçirirsin, yenilersin ya da tümüyle
değiştirirsin. Burada teori ve kanunla
alakalı tekrar bir yorum yapmışım ama
şuraya dikkat etmenizi istiyorum.
Teoriler genellikle bir olayın neden
gerçekleştiğini açıklarken bilimsel
kanunlar aslında nasıl gerçekleştiğini
tarif etmeye bize yardımcı olur. Aşağıda
örnek bir bilimsel çalışma yöntemini
yine şematik olarak gösterdik
arkadaşlar. Olabildiğince hani birçok
bilim dalında da aslında bu yöntemlerin
kullanıldığını size söylemeye
çalışıyoruz. Tabii ki olay sadece
biyolojiyle sınırlı değil. Burada çok
rahat bir şekilde aslında hipotezlerin
nasıl sınandığını işte doğrulandığı
zaman nasıl paylaşıldığını doğrulanmazsa
değiştirildiğini, gözden geçirildiğini,
yenilendiğini size defalarca vurguladık
arkadaşlar. Şimdi o zaman bir tane kara
tahta açalım ve kara tahta üzerinden
şöyle bir tane deney tasarlayalım.
Mesela kendime şöyle bir soru sormak
istiyorum.
Bitkiler
farklı ışık koşullarında
farklı tepkiler mi verirler?
Ya da aynı oranda mı büyürler?
Kendi kendime derim ki acaba güneş ışığı
ya da gölge ya da yapay ışık
bitkileri nasıl etkiler? Bakın bu benim
kafamda oluşan bir soru. Benim için bir
problem. Ben ne yapacağım? Birtım
gözlemler yapacağım. Değil mi? Veriler
toplayacağım.
Ortada bir hipotez oluşturacağım ve
kontrollü deneyler yapacağım. Mesela bir
hipotez kurayım. Bitkiler
güneş ışığında
gölge
ve yapay ışığa göre
daha hızlı büyürler.
Hipotezimi kurdum. Peki şimdi ne yapmam
lazım? hipoteze dayalı tahmin yapmam
lazım. Yapalım.
Eğer bitki
güneş ışığında bekletilirse
daha fazla
büyüyecektir.
Eğer ised
bu da. Tamam hocam.
Şimdi ne yapmam lazım? kontrollü deney.
Ne yapacağım?
Özdeş 3 tane bitki belirleyeceğim. Özdeş
bitkileri
işte aynı miktarda aynı tipte toprak,
aynı sıcaklık değeri,
aynı miktarda su
ama
birine güneş ışığı,
birine yapay ışık.
Diğerini de gölgede bekleteceğim ve
belli periyotlarla,
belli bir süre bu bitkilerin boylarının
uzamasını kayıt altına alacağım. Uzama
miktarını
gün
34 hafta artık deneyin süresi sana
kalmış.
Kaydedeceğim.
Ve ne olacak tabii bu kayıt sonucunda
bir elimde bilgi olacak. Kaydın sonunda
da baktım gerçekten şu anda sallıyorum
işte 4 hafta sonra güneş ışığı altında
bekletilen bitki 5 cm uzamış. Yapı ışık
altında bekletilen 2 cm uzamış. Gölgede
bekletilen 1 cm uzamış. O zaman sonuçlar
benim kurduğum hipotezi doğruladı mı?
Bitkiler güneş ışığında gölge ve yapay
ışığa göre daha hızlı büyüdü mü?
Sonuçlar hipotezi doğruladıysa ne
yapacağım? İşte bunları insanlarla
paylaşmak için bir tez yazacağım.
Anlaştık mı? Gelelim bilim etiğine.
Etik, ahlak, birtım kural ve kaidelere
uymak. Bilim insanının arkadaşlar
olmazsa olmazı olmalı.
Ve hani hem bir yazılı sorusu anlamında
hem de sizler gibi geleceğin bilim
insanlarına yol göstermesi anlamında.
Bakın buradaki not çok kıymetli.
Nedir bu olay? Bir bilim insanı
arkadaşlar yaptığı çalışmalar sırasında
verilerle oynayamaz.
Hipotezi desteklemeyen verileri
değerlendirmeye almama gibi bir lüksü
olmaz. Yani şunu yapamaz. Ya ben bunu
yaptım. benim hipotezi desteklemedi.
Bunu göstermeyeyim. Destekleyenleri
göstereyim. Hayır. Yaptığın çalışmaları
şeffaf bir şekilde başarısı ve
başarısızlığıyla insanlara sunmalısın.
Ya da araştırma sırasında elde edilmeyen
verileri uydurmak,
hiç olmayan verileri raporlamak,
yayınlamak. Bunların hepsi etik dışıdır.
Düşünsenize hiç öyle bir sonuç elde
etmemişsiniz ama elde etmişsiniz gibi
yazıyorsunuz.
Bilimsel çalışmanın bazı aşamalarında
elde edilen verileri manipüle etme,
değiştirmeye çalışma. Aslında o sonucu
elde etmedin ama elde etmiş gibi hareket
etme. Ya da şu var ya şu çok yıldızlı
bir bilgidir arkadaşlar. Keşke dünyadaki
hiçbir bilim insanı bu maddeye aykırı
hareket etmese ama maalesef çok fazla
var. başkalarının yöntemlerini,
verilerini, yazılarını, görüşlerini veya
şekillerini atıfta bulunmadan, onlardan
bahsetmeden, onlara haber vermeden
kullanmak. Yani intihal diyorlar buna
arkadaşlar. Bu maalesef ülkemizde de çok
gördüğümüz olaylardan bir tanesi. Ve bir
araştırmayı yayınladığımız zaman elbette
ki arkadaşlar her bilim insanı prestijli
dergilerde, dünyanın saygın
yayınevlerinde
bir şekilde araştırmalarının yer
almasını ister. Bunun için de tabii ki
gecesini gündüzüne katan bir sürü bilim
insanı var. Ama bazen bilim insanları
bir araştırmayı farklı yerlerde
yayımlayarak sanki çok sayıda yayım
yapmış gibi davranma yoluna gidebilir.
İşte arkadaşlar bunlar etik dışı
davranışlardır.
Ve biz bilim etiğinin temel
prensiplerini konuşurken dürüstlükten,
doğruluktan, şeffaflıktan,
tarafsızlıktan
ve en önemlisi yaptığımız her işle
ilgili sorumluluk alıp o işlerle ilgili
hesap verebilir durumda olmaktan
bahsederiz. Saygı ve onur. Bilimsel
araştırmalarda
insan ve hayvan haklarına saygı
göstermek en üst seviyede dikkat etmemiz
gereken şeylerden bir tanesi. Ve
özellikle arkadaşlar kendi kafamıza göre
öyle denekler ya da herhangi bir canlı
araştırması yapamayız. İşte ben gittim
bugün 100 tane fareyle çalıştım. Böyle
bir şey yok. Bunların etik kurul
raporları alınmalı. üniversitelerde
onaylanmalı ve hayvanlara eziyet
etmeden, zarar vermeden onların da ne
kadar önemli varlıklar olduğunu
gözeterek bilimsel çalışmalar yapılmalı.
Bu çok kıymetlidir. Bir de insanla
ilgili çalışmalar yaparken bakın
bilgilendirilmiş onam denilen bir şey
alınmalı. Yani biz bir bilimsel çalışma
yaptığımız sırada o çalışmaya konu olan
kişinin rızası alınmalı ve yapılacak
çalışma kendisi bunu anlamasa bile
başından sonuna kadar düzgün bir şekilde
kendisine anlatılmalı, izah edilmeli ve
deneklerin hakları her zaman
korunmalıdır.
Bir bilim insanı yeniliklere açık
olmalı.
Elbette ki en önemli derdi toplumlara,
insanlığa ve tüm canlı varlıklara,
doğanın dengesine katkıda bulunacak
araştırmalar yapmak olmalı. Yani amaç
bundan ötesi zaten olmamalı diyoruz.
Genel kültür tadında bir ders oldu ama
ben yine de şuraya bir yıldız atmak
istiyorum. Gözlem yaptım. Problemi
belirledim. Veriler topladım. Hipotez
kurdum. hipoteze dayalı tahmin yaptım.
Kontrollü deney yaptım. Deneylerimin
sonucu tutarlı hipotezi destekliyor. Ve
bunu ben ne yaptım? İnsanlarla
paylaştım. Hatta ne dedim size?
Desteklemiyorsa bile neden
desteklemediği ile alakalı insanlarla
bunu paylaşmam lazım. Sonrasında
hipotezi değiştirirsin, geliştirirsin.
Üzerine yine deneyler yaparsın. Bilimsel
çalışma bu şekilde akar gider.
Arkadaşlar hipotezden bahsettik. Hipotez
verilere, eldeki verilere uygun olmalı.
Deneylerle sınanabilmeli ve eğer deney
sonuçlarıyla uyum göstermiyorsa, bir
tutarlılık yoksa tabii ki değiştirilmeli
dedik. Etkisi araştırılan değişken
bağımsız değişkendir.
Bunun sonuçları ise bağımlı değişkendir
dedik. Hipotez, teori, kanun. Bunlar
birbirine dönüşebilen kavramlar
değildir. Teoriler yüzlerce, binlerce
hipotezle desteklenir. Teori genellikle
nedenlerle, kanunun genellikle
nasıllarla ilgilenir şeklinde küçük bir
sonuç çıkarttık. Kendi deneyimimizi
tasarladık. Mesela bitki farklı ışık
koşullarda nasıl tepki verir? Bunu merak
ediyoruz. Bir hipotez kurduk. Bitkiler
güneş ışığında gölge ve yapay ışığa göre
daha hızlı büyürler. Sonra hipoteze
dayalı tahmin yaptık. Eğer bitki güneş
ışığında bekletilirse daha fazla
büyüyecektir dedik. Sonra kontrollü
deney yaptık. Değişkenlerden sadece bir
tanesini değiştirdik. O da ne? Işığın
kendisi. Geriye kalan her şeyi sabit
tuttuk ve sonuçlar hipotezi
desteklediğinde bunu rapor haline
getirip insanlarla paylaştık. Etikten ve
bilim insanının sorumluluklarından
bahsettik. Sağ tarafta özellikle hem
yazılda çıkmasını beklediğimiz hem de
tabii ki bilim insanlarının
sorumluluklarını içeren bir not kağıdı
var dedik. Bakın, araştırılan hipotezi
desteklemeyen verileri değerlendirmeyi
almama gibi bir şey olmaz. Onu da
değerlendireceksin.
Elde edilmeyen verileri uydurmayacaksın.
Bilimsel çalışmanın aşamalarında elde
ettiğin verileri manipüle etmeyeceksin,
değiştirmeyeceksin.
Başka insanların isimlerini kullanmadan
onlara ait olan verileri
kullanmayacaksın. Onlara atıfta
bulunacaksın. Bir araştırmayı farklı
yerlerde yayınlayarak bak çok fazla
yayın yapmışım gibi davranmayacaksın
dedik ve burayı bitirdik. Arkadaşlar
buradaki bilgi değerlendirme ve etkinlik
soru çözümünü bir sonraki videoya
bırakalım. Hadi bir mola çayınızı,
kahvenizi tazeleyin.